- So, yeah, I'm Kathryn, she, her, hers,
and I'm a third year PhD student
in a lab at here at Rockefeller,
and we study the bacteria
that causes the disease tuberculosis.
You may not have heard of it
because it's not super
big in the United States,
but it's actually the number
one infectious killer.
And when I'm not in lab, like I said,
I like running, I have two cats,
and just to try and get to know everyone,
we have a little ice
breaker about seasons.
So let me pull up the poll.
Yeah, so let me know what
your favorite season is.
I'll give you guys a couple
of seconds to fill that out.
Okay, almost everyone,
there's just like three
people we're waiting for.
Oh, we have people who
have puppies in the chat.
Awesome.
I had a dog growing up,
but now my apartment's too small,
so we have two cats, Fifi and Ellie.
They came with the names
when we adopted them.
So since this is just an icebreaker poll,
I'll give you guys five more seconds.
Okay, and yeah.
There is a slight preference for winter.
My favorite season is fall.
So kind of sad that we're
tailing into winter now.
I like leaves and I like cinnamon, so.
Oh, we have love for summer.
Oh, and a cat.
So cute.
Yeah, so I will, how do I do that?
Sorry, I'm still getting used to Zoom.
Okay, yeah, so just stop me
anytime if you have questions
or something you want to
see more or different,
but you are in a microbio
class, and I study bacteria.
So I wanted to give you
a little bit of a tour
of what our lab looks like.
So you'll notice I have
these purple gloves,
I wrote on this one in Sharpie,
because we want to keep
everything away from us.
So I take them on and off when I go
to touch my phone or touch my computer
just to keep everything clean.
And so I'm gonna take
one off to grab my phone,
but if I'm doing this correctly,
and there's another window where you see
like a blue rack with a
bunch of tubes and stuff,
so if you can see that,
that's just a bunch of DNA,
but looks cool.
So it looks like it's just
water, but there's actually,
oh, actually that tube is empty,
let me get one that has stuff in it.
Yeah, see at the bottom there,
it looks like there's water?
But that's actually a bunch of DNA.
So super cool.
But we're here to talk about bacteria.
So I wanted to show you
guys some different types.
So there are bacteria that most people
have heard of, like E. coli.
Oh, sorry, oh, you can spotlight
two videos, that's so cool.
So most people have heard of E. coli,
either from like food things,
or if you're in a bio class,
you might've heard it in reference
to like cloning or genetic engineering,
but this is what E. coli
looks like on a plate.
You can see there are these
little colonies that grow,
those individual spots,
and then this big section that
we call a lawn or a smear.
Can you see that okay?
Nice.
So there are lots of
different types of bacteria.
So there's E. coli that
most people have heard of,
and then I study what's
called a mycobacteria,
M-Y-C-O, and they look a little different.
It's hard to see from this side,
but before I open them,
we have to turn on the flame.
So I'm gonna try and put this up here.
Oh, cool, you can still see it.
Basically, oh, someone
asked what the DNA is from.
So I actually pulled it out of E. coli,
so out of these cells.
I grew them up in a liquid,
and I put a bunch of chemicals in
to break them open and pull out their DNA
so I can figure out what it is,
and then I can put it into other bacteria.
Basically, I want to use something
that the E. coli have in their DNA,
and I want to express it or make it happen
in a different bacteria,
one of the mycobacteria.
So someone's asked what I mean
by a flame and I'll show you.
So when you work with bacteria,
not only do you need to
protect yourself from them,
we wear the gloves, and if
you work with a pathogen
or a bacteria that causes a disease,
you have to put on like
a different kind of mask
and special like a lab coat,
but we also want to make
sure that the bacteria
that we're working with are protected
from other bacteria that might
be on our hands or in our breath.
So I take ethanol, just
like hand sanitizer
but without the nice smells,
and I wipe down my gloves and my area
to kill all of the bacteria
that are just hanging out on the surface,
and then I turn on a legit flame.
So I'm trying to get it
within both cameras' views.
Nice.
And I have a little striker
here, make a little spark,
some gas comes out of the canister,
and you can see that there's a flame.
So this is called sterile technique.
We use it so that we
can protect the bacteria
from bacteria that we don't want.
So I want to make sure that
everything on this plate
is what I think it is, what I know to be
because I put it on there.
So by using a flame,
you can protect the
bacteria from other things,
just like we use gloves
to protect ourselves.
So bacteria look kind of different.
Let me just take off the
gloves so I can show you that.
Hold on.
So if I can get it to focus, sorry.
Is that focusing okay, or is it?
Probably not super great,
but you can see how they look kind of wet,
kind of like gunky, like
a grape if you washed it,
and then these ones look waxier.
It's hard to tell on the camera,
but there are also like
little dots in the center,
and that's because these two
bacteria grow differently.
Someone asked in the chat, is it true
that the blue part of the
flame is the hottest part?
Yeah, so the blue and white
flame are the hottest,
and then the red and orange are cooler,
and I think it also has to do
with how much oxygen it's consuming,
but it's been a while since I
really investigated the flame.
So I'm gonna leave you with the view
of some very fun bacteria, and
ask a quick science question.
Just a second.
Oh, that's way too high up.
I'll just hold it.
Cool.
So let me just open a poll, one moment.
So I mentioned this before.
I wonder how many of you guys
caught what a pathogen is?
Great.
Very nice so far.
Okay, there are two more people,
but that might be the rockEDU
count and your teacher,
so I'm gonna close the poll.
Stop me if anyone didn't get to.
Okay.
Y'all are great.
You're really killing it already.
Yeah, a pathogen is a microorganism
that can cause diseases in people.
There are also pathogens
that cause diseases in other animals,
but usually when we say pathogen,
we're talking about ourselves
because humans are a little self-centered,
you know how it is.
So I'm gonna stop sharing the results.
But, real quick, some of
you selected a microorganism
that lives in animals and
helps them digest food.
So not all microbes are bad.
Some of them are really good
and help animals like cows digest foods,
and those are commensal bacteria.
The C-O means you're working together,
commensal, living together,
helping each other.
And we have those in our gut
too that help us digest food
and make sure everything's
working all right.
And there are pathogens,
so bacterias that cause disease,
like tuberculosis that I study,
or, like someone brought up in
the chat, the COVID-19 virus,
that's another type of microorganism.
It's a virus, not a bacteria,
but that also causes disease in people.
So while my lab doesn't study COVID,
we share a higher safety level lab,
and I'll explain that in a moment,
with people that do study COVID.
So there are different levels of safety,
depending on how hazardous the microbe is.
So what we're doing here
is called level one,
basically none of this can hurt you.
If I wanted to, I could
like put it on my hand
and nothing would happen.
Then there are level two, where
like it wouldn't be great,
but it probably won't get you sick,
or we can like treat it really easily.
And then COVID and
tuberculosis are level three.
which means it's hard
to treat or dangerous,
and you can put in these external measures
to make sure that you're safe.
So I'm going to quickly share my screen,
or, oh, I can upload a file to the chat.
This is so cool.
How can I do that?
Can I just copy and paste this?
Let's find out.
Ah, it won't let me paste a photo.
Okay, I'll share my screen super quick.
So this is actually my lab in
our safety level three lab.
You'll notice that, because we're working
with pathogen bacteria that can hurt you,
we all have these special masks
or these these hoods on that filter air,
we have these fancy overalls
that are made of plastic to keep us safe,
and we all have hairnets.
So we look kind of silly,
but it's one of the ways
that we can be safe studying
a bacteria that's harmful.
I'm gonna stop sharing that,
but you can see we have a lot of fun,
so science is pretty cool,
and we get to look like we're in a movie,
so who doesn't want to
feel like a movie star?
But not all bacteria are harmful.
Do you guys know that baker's
yeast is a microorganism?
Something that's really small,
but we use it to make sourdough
and other types of breads and things.
And there are different
types of microorganisms,
bacteria, viruses, a fungus,
and then these other
things called archaea.
They're kind of like really old bacteria,
but I don't know a lot about them,
so don't ask me about that one.
Real quick, I just want
to get y'all's opinion,
or would you mind answering this poll
on which of these is not a bacteria.
Oh, forget about the last,
oh, actually, no, go ahead, go ahead.
Which is not a bacteria?
There's more than one right answer,
so you can put in either of them.
And while you do that,
someone in the chat asked
if it's safer with the mask or the hood.
Both are quite safe.
Technically the hood
is a little bit safer,
but we kind of just do it
because it's more comfortable.
Usually it's like a cool breeze
from the back of your head.
And someone says that they have eczema;
me too, that's why I put
it as one of the options.
That may have given away
whether or not it's a bacteria,
but we'll see.
Okay, everybody.
Three more people, I'm
gonna give you 10 seconds.
Y'all are rockstars,
you're doing so great.
Yeah, eczema is not a bacteria.
It's a funny word for a
special type of dry skin
that's kind of itchy and red.
Sometimes it can be quite bad,
but most people like myself
and Joshua and Ethan in the chat,
you just get it in the
winter, little itchy.
You put on some Aquaphor
or some kind of cream,
and it feels better.
E. coli is a bacteria.
You'll remember that that was actually
the first bacteria I showed you.
So one moment, I'm putting on the glove
'cause I want to touch bacteria.
Oh, it made a fart sound.
So it's this guy.
Oh, I just realized,
the person who's not
responding to the poll is me.
It's me from my phone, my bad.
Yeah, so this is E. coli.
Yeah, so it can look kind of different.
This is what it looks like in a plate.
That's pretty cool, it's
like individual dots.
And here, I grew up a whole bunch of it,
and then I spun it really, really quickly
to separate out media,
or like the good juice
it likes to grow in,
from the bacteria itself.
So it's like a gross pellet.
It's pretty cool, though.
Yeah, so that's E. coli,
which is a bacteria.
And then the other option was salmonella.
Salmonella is actually also a bacteria.
I believe it's Salmonella enterica,
just meaning that it's typically
in like the human digestive system.
So we've gone over eczema is
not a bacteria, skin condition,
and malaria is also not a bacteria.
It looks like it might be
'cause it has one of
those good genus species,
those Latin names next to
it, Plasmodium falciparum,
but it's actually a parasite.
It's a type of cell called a eukaryote.
I think you may have covered
that in class, actually,
where bacteria are prokaryotes
and multicellular organisms
like us are eukaryotes.
I'm getting thumbs up, nice.
Yeah, so malaria is a
parasite and a eukaryote.
So that one was pretty tricky,
but you did really
great with all of these.
Nice.
So I'll save the last
poll for a little bit
and just show you some of the cool stuff.
This is like show and tell for me
because I really like doing all this.
So let me grab something
from our big incubator.
I'll bring you with me on my phone
so you can get a good look
at what the lab is like.
Thank you for changing the view.
So yeah, this is my whole bench.
I apologize that it's messy.
I was in the middle of
stuff when you called.
This is you.
Creepy, huh?
This is the thing that spins really fast.
You can put stuff in it,
and it'll separate it
based on how dense it is,
so if it's like really, really
heavy or not that heavy.
And then I'm gonna take
you to the incubator.
We have the tape so that we walk
in only one direction
for the COVID safety.
So we grow a lot of bacteria.
And part of that means we have
to have a lot of incubators.
This machine right
here, it's an incubator.
What it does is keep the bacteria
at the temperature they like to be,
and spinning at the speed they like.
So if we open the door,
you'll see we have a bunch of bacteria.
I wanted to show you this.
This is a whole bunch
of that mycobacteria,
the M-Y-C-O I was talking about.
You can see it kind of makes
like a little gross film on the side.
Let me see if I can get
a better angle for it.
Yeah, but it's like swirly and smooth,
and I think it's really cool,
but it's also kind of gross.
So we have a whole bunch of those
because everyone in our lab
grows a lot of bacteria,
so we need a lot of room for it.
We also have incubators that don't move,
so these are standing incubators.
And instead of putting in tubes
with that liquid like I showed you,
we put in plates, those
little Petri dishes
that we looked at at my bench.
But you'll notice we have
not too many plates in there right now,
but it helps that we have so many
so we can put different plates in
and different kinds of things.
This is one of the things that
I don't know as much about,
but I'm gonna learn more today.
This is our microscope.
It's super fancy.
It has this special thing
up here called a CellASIC.
I don't totally understand it,
but basically we can
put bacteria in a dish,
and then put that dish
inside the microscope here
See that plate over
there where I'm pointing?
We can put bacteria in that,
and that machine will give them the juice,
the media they like to grow in,
and we can watch it grow in
real time on the computer.
So give me one moment.
Enjoy our good mouse pad.
But I know this is a janky way,
oh no, Windows, remind me later.
Let me find a cool video
of bacteria growing.
I know I could just share the screen,
but I can't do that from this computer
'cause I'm not in Zoom.
So come on, no, not Edge,
come on, Microsoft Edge.
Can you see that?
Isn't that wild?
That's that mycobacteria I
was talking about growing.
So we take a picture
every couple of minutes,
and you can watch it grow.
See?
Look, this one gets all
curly because it's a mutant.
I've made it so it can grow
in a special antibiotic,
something that kills it,
but that means there's
something wrong with it
so that it grows all curly,
and we don't know why that is,
and it's so interesting,
and that's what I'm gonna look at.
So today I'm actually gonna
put bacteria in the microscope
that are red around the outside,
it's red on the cell wall.
You may have covered that in class too.
So I can look at how their
cell wall is growing,
like if it's doing the right things
or if something's messed
up, and that's super cool,
and I'm really excited
to see what happens.
But this is our giant microscope.
I'm gonna take you back
out to the rest of the lab.
Yeah.
So we have a good biohazard sign because,
in this other room, we have a B2 hood.
So you'll notice these are all closed,
and there's like glass.
So what you do when you're
working with something,
a pathogen, that can hurt you,
you only work inside one of these hoods.
And there's special air
moving through this machine
so that everything gets sucked inside
and then decontaminated,
because if you just had it out in the air,
it might like get on you
and you might breathe it in.
But this way, all the bacteria,
all the pathogens stay inside.
And we have our good lab coat
that we wear when we're using this.
And then we have special
disinfectants, these cool pipettes.
I'll show you those at my bench.
And we keep everything really safe.
We even have little instructions
so that we don't forget.
And it lets us study things
that would otherwise might hurt us.
I'm just gonna bring you back to my bench.
So we have a lot of these cool hoods.
Only that one gets the
good bacteria in it.
These ones are just to keep stuff clean.
So we'll walk back.
And I'm just checking the time.
Oh, good, we have like
a half hour, I think.
So I have bunched up my gloves,
so I'm just gonna grab a new pair
Just gonna put y'all back
up here for a second,
and show you some of
the cool tools we use.
And if you have any
questions like about this
or about science in general,
just drop them in the
chat, unmute yourself,
whatever you'd like, I'm
happy to talk about anything,
maybe even about like
where I went to school,
how I ended up doing this.
I'm an open book.
But we have some pretty cool tools in lab.
So can I?
Yeah.
This is called a pipette.
Basically, it lets you suck up
and dispense really, really small volumes.
So let's do this one.
We use what's called a microliter.
So a liter, like the big things,
like a liter of soda that
you see at the grocery store,
and then this is 10,000 times smaller.
So itty bitty teeny tiny,
and I'll show you that.
We put on these little,
like, we call them tips.
They just go on top of this,
and it lets you suck up
just the amount you want.
So you bang it on there,
and you'll see that there's
this little clear plastic tip.
And so if I want to suck up
a really small volume of something,
let me grab something to use.
This will work.
And I'll try and show you up here.
It's kind of hard to see,
my camera's not great.
You put it in, you press
that tippy-top part,
suck it up slowly, and
then way right there.
You can't, you see there's
a little bubble there,
I'll pull it up with the
other camera as well.
One moment.
Gotta take off my glove.
Will it focus is the question.
Not really.
I don't know if you can see that there's
a little round drop of water right there.
It's hard 'cause it won't focus, my B.
But it's a super tiny amount,
and it lets us make it
really, really accurate,
so we know exactly how
much is in that drop,
and it helps us to do reactions.
So just to go through some
of the questions in the chat,
do I work on anything else?
Let me actually cover some of these plates
so that I don't waste flame time here.
So not right now.
I used to.
When you go to grad school, like I'm in,
you do these things called rotations.
Basically you try out a
couple of different labs
and things that you study
to decide which one you're
gonna do a thesis in,
a really big study of something.
So I worked in a lab that studied viruses,
a respiratory virus called
RSV, not a big deal.
It's only like really a big
deal if you're pregnant.
But I only worked there
for a little while,
so I'm not super familiar with everything.
And then I worked in a lab that studied
how this protein, an enzyme,
a protein that can do a reaction
or change something into something else,
how this enzyme that
was made by the bacteria
in our guts is able to keep us safe
by fighting bad bacteria,
by cutting them up.
So I did that for a little
while and that was really cool.
And so that's what I've
studied a little bit of.
Oh, it's a bandaid on my left thumb.
Sorry, the cats, you know,
sometimes you pet them too
much and then they scratch you.
Yeah.
Do you study a specific element here?
So part of the research that I study,
technically what I study is how bacteria
that are able to survive in an antibiotic,
a drug that would kill
them, how they do that,
so what are they using
that helps them stay alive.
So basically it's like if
you're already kind of sick,
what things are keeping
you from being any sicker,
and I look at that in tuberculosis,
the bacteria that causes
the disease tuberculosis.
But yeah, basically how are
these really dangerous
pathogens able to survive?
Someone asked, did I always wanna
do this when I was younger?
I always liked science,
but I didn't realize that
I could be a scientist,
like, I didn't have this kind
of thing when I was in school
so I didn't think I could do it,
didn't realize like normal
people became scientists.
And then so I went through high school,
and I had a really nice
teacher who kind of told us,
like, "Oh, you can do this,"
and he encouraged us to
like go to college for it.
So I studied biology in
college, biochemistry,
basically just more chemistry in there,
and then I ended up coming
to graduate school here.
So I'm from Long Island,
I'm from Nassau County,
the middle and the bottom basically,
and then I went to school
on Long Island also.
It's a little early for y'all
to be thinking about college,
but you can always think
about that if you want.
Where is my lab?
So we're at Rockefeller University,
so we're on the Upper East Side,
and then we're in this
open space building.
So someone asked about Ebola.
So I'm actually going
to do a quick Google.
So Ebola is a virus.
Let's see what the CDC says,
'cause they are great at this.
So it's a virus, it's not a bacteria.
So viruses can't multiply
unless they're in a host cell.
So in this case, the virus,
that big piece of DNA ,
can't make more of itself
unless it's inside a human cell.
And that's what it does,
it enters your body,
it goes inside one of those cells,
and it says, "All right,
stop what you're doing,
"make more of me," and then it makes more
and more and more of that,
and then the cell breaks open,
and now each of those particles goes
into another one of the human cells,
and says, "Stop what you're
doing, make more of me."
And that's the cycle and how
it can get to different cells.
Let me see.
Yeah, it's mostly, it's
like a bloodborne disease.
So it'll be if you contact someone
who's infected their blood or saliva
or you're bitten by
like an infected animal.
You might remember that
was a previous pandemic.
So someone, I'll get right
back to the RNA question,
but no, Ebola can infect
different types of organisms.
So here it can infect fruit
bats and nonhuman primates,
basically apes and monkeys,
that kind of thing,
so not just people, just in my
example I was saying people.
Why does this sound like RNA duplication?
So that's a super good point,
yes, Ethan brought that up.
So viruses are just pieces of DNA or RNA,
and so the way RNA kind of
gets turned into a protein
and you make many, many
copies of that protein,
you're just making more and more virus.
It's the same way you like go
from DNA to RNA to a protein.
But in this case, just make a whole bunch
of that genetic material.
Does that make sense?
Cool.
I'm trying to think if
there's anything else
I have cool that's out.
I don't know.
Let's see what else I've got.
So I put on my gloves that way
where I kind of like fill them with air
and then spin them so
that I can use them again,
but I only want to put the side
where my hands are, on this side,
like I only want to put
my hands on the inside
or else I'll have just touched everything
that I was trying to protect myself from.
So that's always fun.
But we have, what other cool
things do I have up here?
These are just more bacteria.
I always think bacteria are cool.
So, oops, I'm moving the wrong way.
Yeah, so we've got some more dots.
These are different pieces of DNA
that I wanted to make and put in,
okay, there we go, put
in another bacteria.
So what these do is
there's DNA inside these
that I will pull out, put
in these little tubes,
and then be able to put in other bacteria,
and it'll turn off certain genes.
And what we'll see is whether or not
the bacteria needs that gene to survive.
If I turn it off and the
cells are still alive,
that means it didn't need it that much.
If I turn off a gene and they die,
that means the cells needed it.
Does that make sense?
Awesome.
What other fun stuff do I have?
These I just think are cute.
Teeny tiny tubes, look
at how small that is.
I think these are adorable.
They're so small.
They're like Chiclets, like that candy.
We have, let me find
something that's not sterile.
Here we go.
So I have this nice rack,
and this is just some, it's
a chemical called EDTA.
You don't need to worry
about what it does.
It's just I wanted to
show you something else.
So remember how we saw
those cool pipettes,
these guys that let us
pipette really small volumes?
We also have ones that let us
do big volumes but really accurately.
So, oh, in fact, we'll
get the flame going again.
Nice.
What you'll do is you rip it open,
kind of like when they do a strep test
or a strep culture at the doctor's office,
and you put it on this thing that,
if you could hear it, it
sucks and spits out a liquid.
So if I put it in this solution,
I can suck up that amount that I want.
So here, this is five.
It's hard to see at this angle,
but there are little numbers on here,
like a graduated cylinder,
and then you can inject it back out.
And you can use that
if you want to take out
a certain amount of something,
and you want to know what it is.
What else do I have?
We might as well.
So the bacteria are on the plate, right?
They're on this thing.
And if I want to pick them up,
what I do is I take these little sticks,
gotta keep them sterile
so I only open them when
I have the flame on,
and you'll notice they have
a little loop on the end,
one second, and I'll put my hand under
like a beauty YouTuber,
that little loop on the end.
And what I'll do is I'll open
the plate with the bacteria on it,
and use the little loop to pick some up.
Let's see.
I don't know if you can see
that I'm like spreading it around.
So this is one of the differences
between that E. coli and mycobacteria.
You'll see that it's like really waxy
and I'm just kinda moving it around.
Looks like it's not all
coming off the plate,
here you can see it's stuck
to that loop a little.
See that beige bit?
Sorry, the focus is really bad.
One sec.
So there's that little
beigey thing on the loop.
That's a bunch of bacteria.
So this is a mycobacteria.
So it was waxy, and I kind
of just like spread it around
when I tried to pick it up.
But E. coli has a different cell wall,
so it's a different texture
when you go to pick it up.
So let's grab this and another good loop.
Grab one of these guys.
So here they look a little different,
and then when I go to spread around
one of these little circles,
you'll see the whole
thing comes up at once.
It doesn't like move around
as much as the others,
and I'll use the other end
to show you the same thing.
So see how it comes all up
at once, it's like creamy.
The E. coli is a creamy bacteria,
and mycobacteria are waxy.
So bacteria have all different types
of like surfaces and properties,
and that's one of the ways
they survive in the body.
So since they have that really hard,
like that waxy outside,
it protects them from the immune system.
So I'm just checking the chat, one sec.
Talking about lab exams.
So yeah, when I was, not right now,
so right now as a PhD student,
I do research and I don't
really get grades on it,
it's just if I am learning
and finding something,
like more understanding how
these bacteria do what they do.
But when I was in high school and college,
we did have lab exams.
So basically they'd give us a task,
like make an experiment to test
if caffeine increases your heart rate,
and we'd have to figure out
how to make that
experiment like perfectly.
So you need to have these
things called controls.
Basically, you want to make sure
that this is because of the caffeine.
So maybe just drinking drinking
increases your heart rate.
So we'd also have like, oh,
some people drank water,
and you want to make sure
you're measuring heart rate the right way.
So we would do that experiment
and then write it up
in a formal lab report,
and then they'd grade that,
both on how well we
designed the experiment,
did it, and wrote about it.
Can the bacteria let
go and leave the plate?
So, no, they, they really like
what the plate is made of.
It's kind of like if someone
made you a bed out of pizza,
you wouldn't want to leave it,
you'd just kind of stay inside.
Oh, we have a thumbs down for pizza?
I'm out, no, no, pizza's great.
And okay, we have a thumbs
up for pizza as well, good.
So they don't just like lift off,
which is quite good for us
because if they were
just going everywhere,
I'd never get anything done.
There are always accidents everywhere.
I've accidentally like
burned myself with the flame,
just like singed my arm
hair, nothing that big,
just like if you're baking or something.
But we do a lot of stuff to keep us safe,
so the gloves, you'll
notice that this is in
like a little carousel thing
so that you can't really knock it over.
Yeah, and then when there's
like a real pathogen,
you'll be in one of those
special safety hoods
that I showed you before,
that kind of thing.
So Duncan asked about asked about astatine
No, I don't know what that is.
Let's Google it, or you can
tell me in the chat, both work.
It's a short-lived isotope.
Oh yes, it's an element.
Okay, yes, yep.
Has almost never been seen.
Interesting.
Huh, apparently it's the atomic number 85
and the rarest naturally occurring
element in Earth's crust.
Oh, it's because it only
comes from heavier things.
So you have to wait for something bigger
to like break up a little
bit to get that element.
That's super cool, thanks for telling me.
Ah, thanks for sharing, that's awesome.
Yeah, is there anything
else you want to talk about?
Have you tried using human DNA?
So not here, we actually, one
day when you can come back
to Rockefeller and do like
the in-person lab experience,
some of the things we do is
like extract our own DNA.
So you can swab your cheek
and then put that in a solution, a liquid,
go through a whole experiment
using different chemicals
and things to pull out your DNA,
and then you get what
looks like a spit ball,
but it's all of your DNA.
Super cool, Rock EDU does that,
so once the pandemic is over
and we're all able to
meet in person again,
that's one of the things you can do here.
There are other labs
that use either human or eukaryotic DNA,
but I don't, I think
bacteria are cool enough,
but that's just my preference.
Yeah, anything else?
- [Host] There's a question about
how many people are in the lab right now?
- Ah, thank you.
I apologize for not seeing that.
So right now I think there
are three or four of us.
So there are about 15 people
who are all part of our lab,
but because of social distancing,
we can't all be here at once.
So we kind of break it up into shifts,
some people come in the morning,
some people come in the
evening, that kind of thing.
So right now it's just a couple of us,
and if we're not at the benches,
science is also a lot of like writing,
so we have desks where we do write ups
and we keep a notebook of
all the things we're doing,
that kind of stuff.
So yeah, there's probably
like three or four of us right now.
What do you think is the coolest bacteria?
Oh man, that's hard.
I feel like I have to say
tuberculosis because I study it,
and probably 'cause my boss is
listening, but I'm not sure.
Maybe some of the faster ones are cool,
and some of the ones
that talk to each other are really cool,
like bacteria can send
signals to each other
to say, like, "Let's all grow at once,"
or bacteria can make their own antibiotics
to attack other species,
other types of bacteria.
So those are really cool.
Those are things like
Enterococcus bacteria
and like Pseudomonas,
Pseudomonas aeruginosa
does that like talking
to each other thing.
Someone asked is human
DNA harder to work with?
It depends.
At the end of the day,
it's the same set of A, T, C, and G,
so the chemical, the molecule itself
isn't any more difficult to handle.
Usually it's just that you like need,
there are special rules
when you're working with stuff from people
just to make sure like you don't
accidentally share someone,
like you don't want everyone
to know everything about you.
So we have some special rules for that,
but same molecule at the end
of the day, which is nice.
Just taking a peek.
- [Host] Nice.
Any last questions before we wrap up?
feel free to unmute yourselves as well
or continue using the chat.
What do you want to be when you get older?
- Me?
- [Host] Yeah.
- Oh, right now I think I
still want to do science,
but ask me again in two years
when I'm doing my actual
like thesis stuff.
Someone, Duncan wants to be a
musician and environmentalist.
That's a really good combination.
You have something more
artistic and creative,
something a little bit more
science-y or policy, super cool.
Someone asked am I the only one
in my family that studies science?
No, so super interesting,
I have an identical twin sister
who is also a PhD student.
She studies another type of
bacteria at a different school.
But no, my dad works for
an office supply company
and my mom was an
elementary school lunch aid.
So no one else in my family does science.
It just worked out that my
twin and I both really like it.
- [Host] Awesome, thank you.
So if there aren't any more
questions, we can wrap up.
Thank you all so much
for being great sports
and asking such great questions
and engaging with us today.
- Thanks, it is awesome
sharing this with you.
- [Host] Thank you.
Bye.
- Bye, everyone.